صور لسيطره الجيش على معسكر قوات الدعم
السريع في ولايه كردفان اذا هذه صور
بثها الجيش يقول فيها انه سيطر على مركز
الدفاع يتبع لقوات الدعم السريع نتابع هذه
الصور مشاهدينا
والجيش السوداني يقول انه سيطر على مقر
قياده الدعم السريع في قطاع كردفان بحسب
ما اورد طبعا الجيش السوداني كان هناك صوت
طبيعي نستمع لصوت طبيعي لهذه الصور
من السيطره
المواقع
كل المواقع المتمرد
في ولايه الجنوب كردفان في مدينه كادوغلي
والحمد لله الان كل المواقع في تحت
السيطره القواتنا المسلحه
وحقيقه
طوقنا هذه المواقع
بالكل القوات
سواء كان الجيش
او الشرطه
واستقلت الفنون
حاربا وترق وراها عدد لا تقض العدد تقدر
ب 19 عربه
ومعظم عربات صالحه وعيدا 18 فرد
وبما فيهم الدابد ذو رتبه النقيب
والحمد لله
نبدا
على اهلنا في ولايه الجنوب كردفان لان
قواتكم الان مسيطر بكل مواقع بتاع الدعم
السريعه المتمردين وايضا
مسيطرين على كل المواقع بتاع الحركات
المتفلته وباذن الله
تعوم سلام في ولايه جنوب كردفان ونحن
جاهزين وهذا هو موقع الدعم السريع فيها
كميه من المخازن يا مخازن التعيينات
لمتابعه المزيد الاخبار والبرامج والقصص
الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات